today I'll show stranger things okay and
an ass-ton of more stuff right now on
fat man on Batman we're here to drop all
the news that's fit to print or tape
yeah
or rock castle Henry and to be fair it's
old news by this point barring it but
it's news to us Joanna's listen news
it's more views that's just some things
we've seen okay and that's why you hang
out Martin Arn he's a writer goddamnit
Marvin Arnie aside from writing comics
and TV and [ __ ] like that
Roy is an editor what he was the
objective film editor the only time Phil
Mader tear that film editor LA Times
that's kind of thing you say that press
goes mark barnard and film editor LA
Times where's the bathroom you waste a
job in a press conference and after
urinate thank you now because me we are
gonna talk this week about a bunch of
things we'll do stranger things last
because everyone's been gone like are
your legs yes yes today is that day
not before that's to come true let's
talk a little bit about Luke Cage which
he and I you and I us we have both seen
the first seven episodes I've been in a
little cage yeah that's right we are
prohibited from speaking at length in
detail about sign and discord and
disclosure grimaces non-disclosure
agreements so that we can't say anything
for to a certain point but I challenge
this NDA by saying this it is [ __ ]
spectacular it really is there I mean
sue me now are oh I'm sorry I told you
the good thing was good it is [ __ ]
dynamite here if I have to rank the
Marvel Netflix show so far and I don't
want to unless somebody's got a [ __ ]
gun to my head right but I'm a comic
book fan we rank [ __ ] here we go that
doesn't make one worse than the other
personal preferences for me write them
up daredevil season 1 and Luke Cage are
almost shoulder-to-shoulder
that's how much I love Luke
right under that Jessica Jones right
under that daredevil season 2 and that's
not said and like that or season 2 I
liked it a lot but Jessica Jones are
some crazy good quality it's just a way
of saying all of these shows are [ __ ]
phenomenal Luke Cage did not [ __ ]
disappoint man like they took a story in
a bunch of different unpredictable
directions told it with a filmmaking
style that spoke to me is an indie
filmmaker
I love the composition I love the in
this weird editing they actually let
some scenes go longer than your
knee-jerk editor and you would love it
wouldn't cut it out so many scenes are
unlike how they need to go out there but
they let it go on for just a couple
seconds more and I'm like I like it it's
nuanced
the other thing they did was something
that that show vinyl did that I liked
which is like have a musical number in
the middle of it somebody's singing now
in vinyl it was like you know flashback
he thing to a famous artist here
cottonmouth who's the villainous of
spoiling it because they've cast that
guy and they said that in the news he
has a club in Harlem that people perform
men he also his background this is I
can't spoil that yeah not too much but
he has a club in Harlem where people
come perform so throughout the show you
have like these wonderful performances
like on stage that are usually cross cut
with some heinous going on or something
thrilling or somewhere in action
sequence really well done and the
infusion of music is something that like
you know every show is that a score but
this this brings you by virtue of the
fact their story set at a club sometimes
they're allowed to like bring in
elements that you haven't seen another
Marvel shows elements that you have seen
in other Marvel shows that are on full
display here S II X from the first
episode it's just like put you kind
put your Chi trying his pants get shimmy
down you see a lot of flesh it is it's
it's pretty is don't watch it with a kid
no unless you want to be like or unless
you wanted to have the talk yeah
to have to talk about why is Luke
uncaged that's that's his dick okay
superpower dick it is yeah there's some
sexing but that's what I like about
these shows like Jason Mewes got blazed
J and my Silent Bob my [ __ ] male wife
said that one point when he was watching
Jessica Jones he goes I don't watch that
no more how's it going means like all I
watched three episodes I don't watch the
rest it's a boy it's awesome he goes
it's too sexy
there's too much sex she's always having
sex and I'm like why are you intimidated
by that's not what I want my superheroes
but meanwhile he's watched Luke Cage and
one of the first things he said was did
you see I'm not like superheroes say
it's not it's not an overused in fact I
believe it gets played in the first
episode and then just the one scene well
they have spoilers I guess but it's the
ones oh it's hot but anyway it's not I
don't want you going like this is all
about sex on Luke Cage but it's sexy
like it's adult it's like if only the
universe was smart enough to know marvel
beyond marvel like if they ever knew of
Marvel's epic line they could called all
the it Netflix shows Marvel epic because
it's just grown up enough they don't
curse they find a very ingenious way to
not [ __ ] curse a lot in the show and
a very sentimental nostalgic way of
working and with a character
performances are fantastic across the
boards my culture we've seen him go to
work as Luke Cage in Jessica Jones who
you haven't seen up till now is a misty
night played by Simone misuk like this
this is a insanely strong female
character that has been around in Marvel
Comics forever but they've now added to
the Marvel Canon in terms of cinematic
universe I guess the TV is included in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe like
strong ask character who could have her
own show in fact she spends so much time
on screen with him it's almost like
their story yeah now if you know that
character from the comics she got a rich
history man like you know spoilers this
don't happen in the series I'm talking
about comic books now
misty night like loses her arm she gets
a bionic arm the Tony Stark builds for
it and [ __ ] and she goes on to date who
not Luke Cage but Daniel Rand
spoilers modern this she gets on can you
believe that [ __ ] so who's got the
middle oh yeah she's gonna call me
oh that's why I wear the scarf to keep
my brains in my assistant I'm a girl
with the brown agon that's why that's
why they don't let us do this she goes
hey Brandon now they're not gonna let us
watch these shows anymore either so you
wanna watch the first seven no no you
can't oh my god it was I've been just I
want one after the other magic don't
know it's got a great sense of place
yeah like you absolutely know I'm
community previously we'd seen like
Hell's Kitchen be kind of Hell's Kitchen
Aid this is [ __ ] hard
yeah it's uptown they reference that all
the time to like there's some weird
things going on downtown but up in
Harlem we take care of our own and
Harlan is totally character here and
it's definitely like the texture of it
feels like it feels real and it is the
blackest show I've seen in a long time
even more than blackish even more than
blackish it's black like it blackest is
blackish yeah this is this is just
flat-out black you black it's yeah but
not in like a don't [ __ ] scare what's
left of old white America whatever is
watching this it's it's it's awesome
it's awesome but it's awesome the way
the wire is awesome yes wire and they
Jerry picked the wire cast wise smartly
smartly but it's kind of like Marvel
does the wire those wires but it feels
very much like that and I know you old
white guys love the wire so you will
also have this there you go those good
way
listen old white club thrilled you were
by the wire it's just like that it's
just like little except he's bulletproof
which is [ __ ] fantastic whenever they
do a fight sequence or fight sequence
he's just like yeah and people go fly-in
and she's and nonchalant yeah like you
bother me like okay fine I can do
destroy you doesn't people that people
in the ceilings through windows they
have a you know like in daredevil they'd
the hallway fight and stuff they have
their version of it it's not so much of
one launch like take but it's Luke
you've seen in his teaching in the
trailer Luke entering a place and just
decimate
with the card or pulls off just a
battering ram and it's ripping pipes out
of the wall and it's so great there's
lots of that there's and there's a shot
cut [ __ ] I want to talk about so bad you
can yeah I thought but there's something
straight out of the comic books Shh I
mean straight like in a lot of character
names are in stuff and the performances
top [ __ ] notch alfre woodard kills
who's the guys playing cottonmouth I
can't pronounce his name
Mahalo Shabazz Ali he's I always said
that's the dude from from house of cards
he's fantastic ass cottonmouth like
honestly they're that he's one of the
most compelling villains that models put
together this is my theory about the
Marvel Cinematic Universe the best
villains are on their Netflix shows
because you got way more time to pull
the tap and like think about the age of
Ultron your mother burger was like I
just want to stop things
Jhoanna Tony needs to be punished and no
motivation music computer whatever [ __ ]
but they got no time because there's
like jam and story down your throat a
lot of action here with TV shows you
when you got 10 13 episodes you pull
that taffy yeah pin is great David
Tennant's purple man is great you know
cottonmouth is great add to that that
Pantheon now the performance of
cottonmouth like it is nuanced and rich
and also alpha why me neither that's us
spoiling because anybody knows the
character Mariah like she's billing to
in the comics she massive villain she's
big but here she played bow for Woodard
she then it was not very big at all but
there's big and talent [ __ ] but
not big and waste but she's another
villain she's also the big bad as well
and she is like they got [ __ ] lucky
getting her in this thing to play to bad
guy like she's fantastic man like I'm
telling you cast across the boards is
dynamite yeah super strong so yes when
you can watch September 30 I believed
that when it comes on they all drop it's
a little sneak preview still in August
telling you the inside count it's worth
the way it really is and you know you're
wondering well you've seen from the
trailer the headband and the and the and
the cops play for at least to beat in
the origin story but the
more oh there's so much more Oh Easter
egg city it's like Easter when you watch
this thing the eggs just start flying
and you just want to eat and you know
shuck the color off and eat them so Luke
Cage man like I can honestly my thumbs
up his thumbs up do Andrew shooting as
his thumbs are up my thumbs straight up
my ass
this show is phenomenal yeah and this
honestly like of all of them now I hold
out hope for [ __ ] iron fist
I really do cuz like they [ __ ] nailed
Luke Cage like it is really enjoyable
man a lot of people go like it's like
modern day by exploitation I didn't feel
that at all no cosplays more like the
Unforgiven yeah dude it was like I'm
done with this yeah why's the once again
it is this excess Marvel does the wire
yeah or does the wire do Marvel maybe
they give each other maybe they
reciprocate we try you go first but Mars
reach around all those tidal things no
Luke Cage [ __ ] watch it put it in
your eyeballs you know what else I
watched on the Netflix tell the get down
oh I wanted to see that this is the bad
lormand of the origins VIP up thing yes
said I didn't know about the baz lurman
thing until later on but I just saw the
posters I was in New York as though the
posters the holy [ __ ] this looks [ __ ]
dope and then when I saw the trailer I'm
like just like 1970s like midnight 7576
in the Bronx and I was gonna sound crazy
the CEG's I'm like middle-aged white man
but I feel this was made for me yes
absolutely it's my era of it I thought
about you every time every episode I
watched like you know what Kevin [ __ ]
loved it does it make you real tear it
does really I'm in you just [ __ ] he
told me if you can [ __ ] get me with
the music and [ __ ] in that time my life
but you get me with emotional as well I
mean what Baz Luhrmann does almost
better than anybody else is capture like
adolescent yearning and and love and
romance and desire and
like ambition he does that almost like
nobody else does set against this weird
like the recreation of the South Bronx
feels arch like everything's always up
fire there's always building smoke
consumer in the distance every train is
just a little bit graffiti it kind of as
a manner because the world is a little
bit heightened but vivid so there's a
bit of like Romeo Jewel and Juliet but
like not a ton but there's definitely a
romance between two people and it kind
of at the core of it and then beyond
that is the creation of hip-hop it is
the and this is great beat in the first
episode where Grandmaster Flash playing
Grandmaster Flash how's that possible
because black doesn't crack my friends
learned it here on fat man I'm right now
like he's playing he's probably now his
early 50s is playing probably somebody
in his early 20s and it doesn't matter
but I can't go on a dude and ice leather
jacket he was broke when he was very
young brothers are young what he's
explaining to a couple of disciples
kung-fu is a huge part of this thing so
really yeah like this 70s coming from
wave and this is one dude who's name is
Shaolin fantastic
ah I'll call him Chou and like there's a
[ __ ] shout but he's explaining exactly
what the get-down is but get down is
every disco record has you know every
song has like four minutes of [ __ ]
like the strings are there singing and
whatever but then there's the drum break
there is like a nice 10 15 seconds
that's the get down beat that is what
the break dancers like to dance to and
so then the DJ's job is to control time
and space is to take that brick and
through the use of two turntables extend
that break like the break and then you
mix together to put to another break and
the brake and the Brandy's the breaks
break it up break it up break dancing
came from people dancing just during the
breaks and it's all about like how
hip-hop was born out of nothing out of
all we have is two turntables on
microphone and we're gonna create an art
form that previously did not exist that
could not exist without the sort of
privation and deprivation and just
ingenuity of these dudes who have no
instruments have nothing beyond stop
talking I'm just gonna go watch it right
now my god you [ __ ] over solder
that's fantastic I want it you watched
every episode so far watch it they drop
six and then there's notice six coming
in 2017
really the fix is not an hour long yeah
like an hour and a half right and the
pilot episode is I will say Oh Rocky
okay you gotta screams all over the
place but make it through - to make a
thought it's sweet red and yeah so is it
are they real characters if you know so
that's all but every now and again
you'll get oh hey DJ Kool Herc and is
there's Grandmaster Flash they talk
about mr. Halloween like they're doing
all of this stuff but they're all like
sort of is there any hint of South Bronx
sound stuff oh I can't wait man there's
I do want to have some character says
this is we gotta go your mouse is making
the rice and running with the government
cheese that loose meat chili we got to
go I'm like government cheese you're so
mean I just do a whole [ __ ] SModcast
episode about government cheese oh my
god now I have to say it this way the
posters look good man I love that era of
hip-hop the beginning of him up because
I think there's so many rich stories to
tell look you can tell the story about
you know 20 years in the hip hop with
with Straight Outta Compton but like you
know like the Run DMC story which is a
little bit told and Krush groove that's
a fascinating [ __ ] story like when we
had DMC on comic book men he talked he
made his parallels between comics and
and like he's like that the terminology
the very visual terminology we used like
we bust through walls knock down doors
he's like that came from comic books and
the I'm number one I'm the best I'm the
greatest also came from comic books so
he's got tight tied to comics but he
sold his collection to buy what mmm
turntable microphone so that I could
start from DMC so like [ __ ] like that
like I would love to watch Run DMC movie
man or just story a lot of early hip hop
accident even now of course but
particularly then like you're talking
about the birth of something like you
said man they've created something out
of [ __ ] nothing so all of these
stories or permutations are the same
thing
pioneers revolutionary stepping out
there and being like look at wicked does
that work with the with the work oh my
god like a one-time thing
so I can't wait
and it's always fun it's always just
there's this charge you get when you
watch a scene where they're creating
something like when it's Ray Charles
like inventing what I say on the scene
like we don't have any music rap songs
and just follow me
do what I do say what I say we're making
it happen as you're watching right and
this has a ton of that of the holy [ __ ]
we're watching this guy in Venice right
now we're watching them write this song
on the stage we're watching this dude
discover them he's a rapper
like he'd always been a poet he'd always
been a wordsmith but he'd never gotten a
microphone you've never ridden a beat he
never like performed in front of people
and to see that happen for the first
time breathtaking all the dreams all
hopes all the heart palpitations it's
really good
amen anybody in it that it was a new
people harmony shooter here or over
there um I am not entirely sure because
they spent 120 million dollars on this
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] for six
episodes work for that for the twelve
but that's a game of Thrones Season one
month yeah and apparently creating 1976
the Bronx is as difficult as it is to
create Westeros yeah we're like we've
got to build all this [ __ ] you've got a
gorgeous garde Detroit and shoot because
Detroit feels like it's barely a city
anymore but just like we gotta get
trains with graffiti on we got to get
walls and break them down we gotta get
like vast lots with just junked cars
take a little on it took a minute to do
that no I'm dollar what Jimmy Smits is
in it Oh Giancarlo Esposito hello van is
in it Grandmaster Flash ninja Kool Herc
all right it Wow
I think who else is in it the kids are
all new kids are all new control new
except for the guy playing Sheldon
fantastic excellent name twin is the
best name I was also in dope he was a
leaving dope oh right on yeah so a big
recommend big records are making out
like bandits on Netflix lately yes
unknowns coming into prominence with
shows that people fall in love with the
get-down is fairly new but so is
stranger things but stranger things as
captured only to the summer it really
I mean you've now watched I've seen two
episodes I just got to go deeper I've
just been busy and when Luke Cage app
and I had to watch that fact I'm a
marvel guy and a DC guy I'm I'm
accountable guy but the I so I have yet
to go deeper on strange things but I
absolutely loved it
I love the font I loved everything about
it it seemed like it was found a found
TV show of something that was like oh we
found this in the vault this was a show
that happened in the 80s
it looks period people's hair is period
of course but the way it's shot these
duffer brothers managed geniuses I asked
Mojo's like you think they grew up and
we did or do you think you can only do
something like this out of a sense of
reverence and you didn't grow but he's
like my guess is there were babies when
these movies were happening so and then
when they were in their teens like we
went back to the movies of the 70s they
went back to the movies the 80s and they
fell in love with the genre in there in
doing this telling the story which is
very eighties influence they just went
for all the trappings of it and it makes
all the [ __ ] difference do it even as
you're watching the [ __ ] opening
credits happen yeah it just feels period
yeah crazy opening credits are super
[ __ ] carpenter yeah I like the music
that this [ __ ] synth pop is in there
it's like Stephen King meets Steven
Spielberg and just meld it into this
awesome like weaponization of nostalgia
yeah absolutely knows exactly what you
want out of that it definitely it was a
tip of the hat to super 8 it feels like
yeah like certainly not the same thing
but like Jay Jay feels like you got to
that territory that Goonies explorers
territory like a minute for the duffer
brothers and they just did it in a
different direction and had a lot more
time to do it and boy this [ __ ] 2
episodes I watch for like jaw-droppingly
good yeah I mean in the [ __ ] cast
those kids are astounding they seem like
somebody went through a time portal yeah
and grabbed kids from the 80s
normal-looking [ __ ] kid kids and said
all right go yeah and they can act their
asses off yeah like that casting
director should not work on it
yeah whoever that is has got the I
that's the yes agreed if you find a cast
that exceptional that Young's never
worked before like it's one thing when
you see like the casting of the Avengers
movie not taking anything away from that
casting person but yeah famous people
and you can count on them a little bit
of the box office but you know casting
director who captures your attention
your imagination is the one that's like
I found you these kids that the whole
world is watching right now and everyone
thinks they're genius actors and stuff
but nobody knows them could because I've
just brought them to you and then like
cherry-picking people from like the
ether like Winona Ryder where should we
get went on the writer for this
give me Matthew Modine for this Matthew
Modine to 80s icons as well yeah and
like it just it all holds together so
well your five deep in it and five deep
in it and I'm watching with my son my
twelve year old and it's going well it's
going all for him although it's funny to
watch because the nostalgia doesn't work
at all of him music why it what this
song sucks you like everybody your mind
not only not left below you should get a
[ __ ] cell phone idea buddy they had
walkie-talkies with the closest to a
cell phone that they had and they're
using walkie-talkies oh my god that's
right all the storytelling elements that
are not at your disposal the kids can't
be like did it with text on the screen
or there's no like google it no you
can't go yeah I got a CB radio and hope
you can talk to the other side maybe
possibly yeah my Wi-Fi are just like in
it because it is speaking entirely to us
keep watching this is kinda like there's
kids in it I'm a kid so going wonder
what happened I think maybe that is
another dimension maybe like he's very
tentatively on his way but while I'm
[ __ ] in there he's on his way I'm
waiting for him what do you think it is
just the gestalt of great storytelling
told for the particular prism the
gimmick if you will seems to be what
draws people in initially but the story
is what keeps us all kind of like we all
give a [ __ ] about 11 yeah then I think
it's you would give a better
we care about what happens to will later
on look what happened to barb get to
what happens to barb
yeah I think it's just it's a well-told
mystery it's like a scooby-doo writ
large you know in the bed scooby-doo
meets ET meets Akira
you know they find me they do oh my god
good ball yeah good full you know just
tortured and tested the power child by
you know and there's also this bit this
weirdness of and it happens having a lot
in the 80s but still happens the fear of
the girl on the verge of puberty be like
the hidden power single single we got
some right income and good but it was a
big Stephen King chocolate scary it's
firestarter you know it's it's the it's
there's another movie coming out next
week called morgan with kate mara but
it's all about it's hannah it's ex
machina it's what do you do about this
woman who's experiencing her womanhood
for the first time and we don't know how
to wrestle with this much power but like
it's the the male gaze and the feminine
power and not knowing what to do with it
and it's a powerful motif it's and it's
an enduring motif I mean it's all over
Greek mythology it's Pandora's box it's
like what do you do when you open this
thing that nobody said were open before
oh [ __ ]
don't world let's get go nuts goddammit
pause go to a two-shot Jesus Jesus you
know what I'm saying
you thought you liked stranger things
then you here through this prism back to
a signal back to a single but that's
that's at the core of this the core of
this is a afraid of the sort of
knowledge and wisdom of children and but
also afraid of this oh my god this girl
can do things that nobody's ever seen
before we have to get her back and chin
her up and channel her power through the
sort of adult male perspective
Fuli she needs to be a weapon for us
right and we want her to be free the
story wants her to be free to find her
own path and that's amazingly powerful
it's astoundingly powerful and it's the
reason why it indoors from decade to
decade to decade from Stephen King to
Spielberg to Brian De Palma to
everything stranger things you guys we
should watch this whoa
if that doesn't convince you to give it
a roll you got your head up your ass the
whole world is talking about stranger
things why aren't you watching it you
look we're ready get off our dick fine
for
but if you have it that will [ __ ] put
you in the mood man be like alright let
me try one if you try one to try to run
yeah III marry my friends dreamer II
what else we got in the news Kubo on the
two strings I loved it I saw I saw it in
a theater yes and supposed to this is
the like of people that did Coraline and
boxtrolls yes like beautiful work they
still do stop-motion there's not like
actual clay puppets or puppets that
aren't clay whatever [ __ ] but like not
not computer animators there is if
there's any computer animation it's so
sparse that you couldn't even pick it
out but the thing I love about this
stuff is that it it is the definition of
movie magic you know it is cuz movies
kids at home not sure if you know this
it used to be film used to be pictures
like 24 frames per second is how movies
work and your mind allows you to forget
that there's still pictures it tricks
you into thinking that it's motion and
that's what movie magic is if the
tricking you into thinking that motion
is a set of still frames [ __ ] so
eloquent I'm a filmmaker and that never
even thought of it like that well done
but we forget that because computer
animation of digital photography sort of
removes any races there's things a 24
per second frame rate doesn't really
exist them exist in a world of 29.99 909
30 frame rates that's gone to accept you
know when you're doing stop-motion you
are still taking those pictures each one
of those things is click move move move
on this scale that is astounding to see
when there's 50 characters in a scene
and there's crepes flying and there's
birds chirping and each one of those
things needs to be moved click move and
it you you it's one V magic edits
realist and true artistry and true
artistry like any jackass can stand in
front of a camera be like you know I'm
mad cuz I'm stuck working a Quickstop
all day and stuff not to take anything
away from Brian on here you've met her
any jackass can stand there with a
backwards baseball cap and say [ __ ]
nothing on camera that's not artful and
doesn't take talent to make a [ __ ]
was it called you know
and the teachers to make Kubo on any
strings move it takes crafts men or
woman ship and detail-oriented
filmmaking that I'm just not capable of
most filmmakers aren't to be honest I
mean nobody does this anymore because
it's both expensive and time-consuming
there's easier ways to do it
I mean like is like what What did he say
we wait what computers they are you know
they're you know just the way Chris
Nolan it's like I still shoot film yeah
I won't shoot video I'm a film guy
like us just like we'd like doing what
we like this is what we like to do we
put all our heart and soul into this and
we stand next to these movies and
proudly and yeah maybe they don't light
up the world like Pixar but [ __ ] you man
time will tell it's all about legacy and
building a library that we're proud of
and the like a library is unlike
anything else thank you very much um so
you recommend I do it's a beautiful
movie what's the story uh it's a simple
movie it's about this kid who it's all
set in Japan it's an ancient story as a
kid whose father died when he was even
before he was born and his mother's been
raising him as the father died he lost
an eye his uncle there's no grandfather
the Moon King it's all mythical stole
his eye once his other eyes so that he
can see into the world of the living
moon King kind of a little bit in the
dead but his mother's been protecting
his entire life keeping him out of this
side of it you know out there today
can't go out at night because the moon
can see him at night hmm he'd been
following these directions his entire
life until he decides he doesn't want to
one time and his mother dies as a result
what yes kids movie I guess somebody's
mother Esther diets is somebody's
mother's gonna die so the N goes on this
quest to to find his father's armor
which will protect him in the fight
against the Moon King but the power that
he has is because his mother's will been
magic in his father was a super great
samurai warrior is what every plays his
little guitar ething whose new strings
he can make paper come alive like
origami and so this movie is all about
this guy play his guitar on this paper
just flying in the air for me dragons
and boats and sea monsters and
everything and it's just so lovely and
it's just it's a simple fable to
Qwest find the armor defeat my
grandfather and get my life back of
course there are twists and turns and
I'm not going to give away the ending
but it's just this lovely fairy tale
just writ large and executed with this
artisanal quality to it it's just
delightful
you got me bona ticket when it came out
like two weeks ago did you well okay
they all do okay look it's like a movies
are never going to be Pixar movies it's
not about the box office with these
films I mean what they'll make I mean
each one seems to make about 90 to 100
million worldwide and they cost about 40
or 50 million to make to break even
they're making it a little bit and they
get to make more and it seems like
that's what this company is about just
being around to make more of them last
three things we're going to talk about
and then send you off into that good
night to think about the things that
mark has told us today runaways is gonna
be a show on Hulu yes did you ever read
the book no that's marvel buck where the
kids are yeah the kids find out that
their parents are super villains they
were they were basically races rich kids
whose parents had stuff and they have a
sentinel Pet Sentinel or is that another
book I'm thinking um this were the one
of us a pet dragon a pet dinosaur I
think interesting to now say but your
brain cave on wrote it okay Adrian off
Fona did the art and once upon a time
later on down the pike Joss Whedon took
a run on writing it for about an arc or
two I think but it's a beautiful book
like a well felt story like about kids
coming to grips with who their parents
are on who they are as a result of who
their parents are who their parents are
super villains right it was a little
like wanted like Mark Millar's wanted
but more like you know charting your own
destiny separate from your parents my
wanted was very much about embracing who
you are but where this is about trying
to discern who you are while dealing
with the responsibilities of what if
your dad is like senator do you have to
grow up to be evil or can you can you
take your fate in your own hands oh my
good it's gonna be on hulu hulu who's
around uh do you name Josh Schwartz and
his partner Stephanie Savage Josh
Schwartz best known for
girl they also do the OCR now I think it
might have also done the OSI um Wow
right on yes that's good it'll be on the
who lose they bought a pilot and a
couple of scripts heading towards the
series order and because it is part of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe being
produced by the Jeff lobes and the
Marvel folks who knows it is Runaways is
nice
who knows who they could cross it mmm
cross over cross off Punisher shows it
the tick the Amazon is I've seen the
pilot the pilot is now streaming on the
Amazon man it's good yeah it's good who
played the thick Peter Serafinowicz who
you will it you'll recognize him to me
you see him but he is also the leader of
the Nova Corps Nova squadron in
guardians of the galaxy oh the guy from
Edgar Wright stuff yes yes that dude he
was in Shaun of the Dead yeah yeah
absolutely the their third roommate Wow
does it really yeah
she created it so he wrote and directed
it how awesome is that how rare is that
happened yeah oh how cool for him and
it's kind of fun because I wasn't an
overwhelming fan of the other live
action show magic wall garden who I love
but it was so much a sitcom because they
could not do the bigness right in
live-action now they can do the bigness
so there's giant [ __ ] that happens in
the tick that you just go to do one
let's miss animation is chair face
Chippendale and if not in this one but
one can only hope so you go to Amazon
voted up and then you get more and then
you get more and they want to make more
Amazon I like this company to you bonsai
future own buckaroo banzai but I could
check out the Tenzin yeah there are good
things with up the tick you can watch
right now on Amazon the pilot yes last
thing we're going to talk about this
excites me cuz I'm like well this is a
good idea yeah tell them the Lost Boys
so ready for a television show more
easily you know what I'm saying and
they're gonna do it where the CW of
course they're gonna do at the CW best
[ __ ] place for it matters
and who's gonna be creating it Rob
Thomas of course eyes on a zombie and he
also did the Carrie Diaries and he also
did Veronica Mars but The Lost Boys good
idea right so I can't believe nobody
tried this before as long as there is an
episode an entire episode devoted to
shirtless sax guy yeah that's all I want
and think about a man they've got like
that movie was ahead of its time those
kids were into comic books they worked
at the comic book store and [ __ ] like
that right now the fingers on the pulse
so I look forward to I think that's a
good idea in terms of like old movies
you can change to TV show [ __ ] yeah I've
watched little [ __ ] out a lot Holies
fits in on the CW [ __ ] yeah in a world
where they're losing the Vampire Diaries
bug in this slot writing yeah right yeah
slide in like a vampires Fang into your
jugular
just keep it relevant I'm gonna [ __ ]
a genie Goertz to come back maybe she'll
be like the old well they could get
what's-his-face to Kiefer Kiefer could
come back and come back Jami Gertz
Jason Patric can come back the old man
is gone right a little hair or whatever
his name was yeah one of the Cory's is
still around Cory could come back with
Feldman Corey Haim unfortunately gone so
yeah you could do a lot of like [ __ ]
like [ __ ] man they gotta get Kiefer
to play the part of the old guy because
that'd be fantastic right put him in the
button-down sweater and [ __ ] like that
we don't make one for all the damn
vampires yeah hey man I'm excited that's
a good idea a lot of good ideas coming
at you in the very near future we're
happening right now
stranger things man Luke eight soon they
get that right now stranger things and
they get down right this very second if
you want Kubo
in theaters right now support some good
[ __ ] runaways ticking a tick right now
on Amazon at least one Lost Boys and
runaways you got a little bit of a wage
a Petukhov yeah that's worth waiting
this is the [ __ ] we stay alive for I
don't know about you I'm sure you got
families and love in your life but I
stay alive from project to project and
like I just want to die but I won't
until I see this Lost Boys on CW one
more
thing to live for your string enough of
those together that's what you call a
life not well lived but a life and
that's our that's one to grow on
that's all we got time for here on fat
man on Batman man tune in next time
we'll tell you some more stuff till then
I'm Kevin Smith I'm hawkman Hardin and
we'll see you next time on fat man I'm
Batman same fat time in same fat Channel
spot cast calm or youtube.com slash
Kevin Smith
hey man it's me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder